the jurogan experience what is going on
today where this is such a hot topic
like what has happened i mean
what has been the shift in our culture
is is
can you find a patient zero it was there
an initial explosion that led to the
domino effect like what
what is it that's leading to such an
utter
fascination culture wide
about gender and sex now it's like these
these hot sauce these are the big hot
topics of today
it's gender sex race and those those
things seem to i guess
also sexual orientation gender sex race
sexual orientation those three
i mean those four it's just
unprecedented in our time that these are
the most widely talked about subjects
across the board with young people and
people that are virtue signaling and
people that want to be you know air
quotes woke
like what's what's causing this colin
help us out you know it's something i've
been tracking for
for quite some time like a bounty hunter
yes
exactly well i was always so i started
off in like the new atheist movement and
i was
arguing against creationists and stuff
and defending biological realities
and then that kind that movement kind of
dissipated and or at least is not nearly
as prevalent and they don't
what happened with the new there was i
think atheism
plus yeah i mean there's actually an
interesting
segue between atheism plus and the the
modern social justice
oh yeah i see it now i mean for sure
atheism was the first movement to be
infiltrated by all the language we're
hearing now of you know
appropriation and the whole um you know
check your privilege and
well i remember that stuff yeah i
remember watching atheism plus
conferences online going
yeah this is like the the craziest
virtue signaling
event that i've ever seen in my life
because it's people that don't just want
to talk about the concept of
agnostic thinking or atheism they want
to also
attribute a bunch of social values
to this movement that makes it kind of
like a religion
have you heard of elevatorgate yes with
richard dawkins
yes involved in that yes yeah that was
sort of the thing that sparked off
in a big way the the rise of a lot of
social justice stuff and the fall
could you explain it to people that
don't know what it was about yeah it was
a while ago let me see if i can
outline it a bit here so there had been
some
complaints at a lot of atheist
conferences where
there had been people complaining of
sexual harassment
and there was one specific example there
was a speaker her name was
rebecca watson she went by skepchick
and she was giving a talk at this
conference
specifically addressing sexism and the
atheist movement
and she i think she might have said that
she wasn't interested in
in you know hooking up at conferences or
whatever and then on the way back to her
hotel
later that night she went into the
elevator and then
someone went to the elevator with her it
was a guy and as they were going up in
the elevator
he looked over at her and just asked her
if she'd like to come back to his room
for a cup of coffee that's like that's
literally what he said
um that's you know that's a euphemism
for you want to come back and
netflix and chill netflix and chill yeah
and so
she said no he didn't pursue any more if
they went off to their separate rooms
everything was fine next day on social
media she blows up the internet trying
to say that how
terrible this was how she felt so
uncomfortable in the elevator it was in
a
tight tight spot you know small elevator
and this how threatened that she was
and it became a really big sort of
fissure in the atheist movement because
some people were saying like nothing
really happened he
they just used a euphemism for you know
they asked you politely if you wanted to
come back and do more you said no like
that's the end of the story
and then there was this atheist named pz
myers who's since sort of
lost his mind and
on his blog he was talking about this
event and then
richard dawkins in the comment section
wrote what's known as the dear muslima
letter which is he was writing a
sarcastic
response to this as he as though he was
addressing some
random muslim woman saying like you know
dear maslima you have no right to
complain about how you're treated you
know having your genitals mutilated or
whatever
because haven't you heard this one woman
her name is skeptic
you know she was offered coffee at an
elevator and she said no and the guy
didn't do anything after that so it was
a very sarcastic
way he he approached that and then that
just made the whole atheist woman just
get engulfed in flames immediately it
was all the factions
split up between the super woke people
and the classic
skeptics and yeah that was never
recovered really and right after that is
when
atheism plus came out which was atheism
plus social justice which really just
was woke democrats who happened to be
atheists
basically and all the new conference
topics were just like
intersectionality and maybe some vague
reference to
you know disbelief or something so uh
the atheist movement never recovered
from that it was it's gone downhill
and now we've seen how the same type of
activism has moved in and taken over
you know evergreen state college and has
led to what brett and heather have gone
through and
then it's sort of erupt all over erupted
all over the country and what we're
seeing now
so that was sort of a the canary in the
coal mine for a lot of what we're seeing
now
what do you think is causing it like
what
i mean a lot of people have theories on
this but i want to know your personal
one like what is
why is this a thing today
yeah well there's so many different
aspects to the ideology
so in the specific area of i guess the
whole
sex denial thing i think there's this
sort of this allergy to to the word
discrimination
in a way where we've been told that
discrimination is a terrible thing
always but i mean it might sound
controversial but discrimination just
means that we're
distinguishing between two different
things in a certain context
right we think of discrimination we can
yeah i'm discriminating
in this certain this certain thing i
mean if you if you have a children's
sports league
that discriminates against adults and
most people would say that that's a good
that's a good type of discrimination
right but we've just sort of adopted
this idea that
discrimination is really bad and so now
when we talk about
uh trans women in sports or something
you know they think they're being
discriminated against and
what you'll see in the headlines is you
know women and girls are not able
who are trans are not able to play in
sports for women and girls
what they fail to mention is that it's
not the fact that they're trans
is the reason why they're not being able
to compete it's the fact that they're
you know biologically male
and that's the the thing that's being
kept
that we're trying to discriminate
against not the fact that they're trans
because
trans is just like a state of mind that
they can have they declare that they're
trans
you know you can't verify it empirically
in any way
and um so there's just there's no reason
to segregate sports by
just a state of your mind basically
anymore that you would want to segregate
sports by
political ideology or something else
that's completely irrelevant
so i think an adversion to the the
concept of
uh the idea that discrimination is bad
just across the board
is is holding us back from having more
productive conversations
and then i know you've had people like
james lindsey on and they talk about
just the the critical theory the queer
theory that's out there where it's just
meant to just pick apart anything
anytime there's they see a binary they
need to deconstruct it and deconstruct
it
and there's it's based on this
epistemology
of relativistic um you know relative
truth um blurring borders between other
things systems of power
this is sort of the ideology that has
taken root in a lot of different areas
in society and
and it's really been coming to a head in
the last few years on on many topics too
on
the whole sex and gender debate we have
the critical race theory stuff we have
the post-colonial
you know decolonize the curriculum and
you know it's just it's spreading out of
control and then people who who are not
who are
who are not the postmodern type people
who are
you know have the enlightenment values
and and we're modernists in the way we
approach the world we think that
you know if something's true if it
corresponds to reality and there's
certain truths that can't really be
denied by anybody
a lot of us are pushing back and because
we've seemed to have lost a lot of
a foothold in the institutions it's now
resulting in
you know people getting canceled yeah
it's a strange time in that regard
where it just it seems like no one knows
exactly
what our our cultural framework is
anymore for discussing things and every
time
the the it gets pushed further and
further along you have to kind of catch
up with what you're allowed to say and
what you're allowed to
talk about and what's okay like it
didn't used to be controversial to say
there are two genders there's only two
genders but if you say it today
you could get fired from your job i mean
that's a real thing you can get
discriminated against you can
not the discrimination is bad as we've
discussed but you know what i mean it's
like it's
this is a new thing to get to a position
where
talking about biological facts
you really shouldn't you have to discuss
the societal agreement the cultural
agreement we have
about like how we view or you know this
is what what the
the push is or what you know this idea
of uh
compliance forced compliance into this
ideology you have to
you have to accept what we view now
as sex and gender yeah there's like a
language takeover
yeah and even when you said just earlier
a second ago that there's you know
there's two genders
well they've just co-opted the that word
gender
and so what used to be the case and this
is something that i was on board with i
was a good
you know considered myself progressive
was a lot of people would say
that sex and gender are different things
sex referred to your reproductive
anatomy your biology
and gender referred to just the way you
identify you know you can identify
as a man or a woman or you know if they
want to expand
that whatever that means um it has to do
with identity it's sort of like
sex is your hardware uh gender is your
software where you can be a male and
identify as a woman
and that was something that i was sort
of willing to get on board with and i
was like
okay why do we need to have the same you
know we
already have male and female to refer to
sex why do we need to also use
men and women maybe we can just let you
know the
those people have have that because as a
biologist
it didn't really my
my defense didn't really go up because
as long as we're we know what sex is
then that's fine i can i'll be willing
to manage that and then slowly over time
that distinction became more and more
blurry
where now they would say instead of that
identify as a man or a woman they say i
identify as a male
or a female and they're using the sex
terms where they used to use gender
terms
and then i'd started seeing on my
facebook popping up people with phds in
biology
sharing articles like there are five
sexes or there are seven different sexes
or sex is a social construct
and this is
i started pushing back against that i
thought there must have been talking
about gender identity but it
became very clear that no they're
talking about actual
sex itself and that there's you know
every different chromosomal arrangement
that someone can have like if you're a
kind filter male or something you have
x y y uh chromosomes that you're your
own
unique sex now rather than just you know
a variation within
within the male the male sex do you have
a theory as to what
what caused all this or as to why it's
it seems to be progressing it's not it's
not like they reached a point and they
went okay
i think we made our point let's uh let's
sort of normalize this and have it be
accepted into the
the common you know thoughts of people
but that's that's not what's happening
it says like it keeps getting
weirder and weirder and weirder it's
like he pushed the envelope about
what it means yeah there's no one
to put on the brakes really i mean
they're within the institutions
and the people who would normally want
to speak up um
like like i did they get called names
they you know i was looking for
tenure track positions and i had people
post on on job boards in my field that
thousands of biologists look every day
that i was a transphobe and a race
scientist that they just
threw in on top of things just to you
know throw a bunch of slurs at me and
see what sticks and try to
poison the well for my my my potential
hiring
and so people see that that happens and
then they just they just don't want to
do it they stay quiet
right and then so while you hear is the
the loudest voices the most activists
uh they come out and they'll they'll
just say this type of stuff
and then a lot of people don't want to
say anything because they're generally
confused because of the jargon that's
being used
um and then they're kind of do a human
shield aspect where they're
they're portraying themselves as the
next evolution of
lgbt rights or in the terms of critical
race there were the this next civil
rights movement
and so no one wants to be on the wrong
side of history even though they don't
understand what people are saying
sounds nuts but who are they to really
judge what this is they just they don't
want to be called a racist because
that's the worst thing you can be called
they don't want to be called a
transphobe because we all want to be
accepting people
and fortunately i think a lot of people
are sort of
beginning to see that and they're
willing to stand up a little bit more
now and at least
call it like it is saying that these
people have a really bad concept of what
biological sex
actually is no there's not seven sexes
no
sex isn't a you know a bimodal
distribution
where we're just varying degrees of
maleness and femaleness you know we can
we can definitively say for you know
4 999 people out of out of 5 000 that
they are unambiguously male or female
uh and you know we can account for the
one percent that's not but
um that doesn't make all of us sort of
in question
of what what our sex is catch new
episodes of the joe rogan experience for
free
only on spotify watch back catalog jre
videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly
switch between video and audio
experience
on spotify you can listen to the jre in
the background by using other apps and
can download episodes to save on data
cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode
of the joe rogan experience